okay so this serious story has many
people on the left in a knot
like I said and we have to talk about
that remember when Donald Trump claimed
that there were thousands of Muslims
cheering about 9/11 dancing in the
streets or on rooftops I think the
phrase was and of course that was a
total and utter lie just didn't happen
absolute lie now there actually are
people dancing in the streets over
Donald Trump's decision to pull troops
out of Syria those people are called the
Taliban NBC News is reporting that
senior members of the Taliban which is
still around believe this to be a sign
of victory getting closer that their
seventeen years of struggle have been
worthwhile that this withdrawal should
serve as a lesson to Americans not to
mess with them now is that a reason that
the United States should stay in Syria
absolutely not but what's very
interesting is that longtime left-wing
Authority Noam Chomsky happens to agree
and I'm getting emails from people who
have genuinely no idea how to react how
to how to react to this Noam Chomsky
recognizing the importance of the Kurds
as a sort of moderating influence in the
region
told the intercept in an interview a few
days ago that US troops should stay in
Syria to deter attacks on the Kurds
saying quote the other crucial question
is the status of this Kurdish areas
rojava in my opinion it makes sense for
the United States to maintain a presence
which would deter an attack on Kurdish
areas the idea that they should be
subjected to an attack by their bitter
enemies the Turks or by the murderous
Assad regime I think is anything should
be done to try to prevent that is this
correct merely because Noam Chomsky says
it of course not should it make the left
say hold on a second let me think this
through when even anti-colonialist
anti-imperialist Noam Chomsky is saying
something about this doesn't make sense
we should probably be thinking twice
about it and I want to be really clear
I'm not
to hide the big picture of Noam
Chomsky's view on this his view on this
big picture is exactly what I've been
talking about since day one which is
Chomsky is generally opposed to our
presence in the region what is the
United States doing in this region big
picture we should be out I agree with
that given that we're currently
entangled in a bunch of different ways
there we should think through each
decision carefully and deciding to
withdraw by first pulling support from
the Kurds is exactly the wrong decision
so what's important to understand here
Pat is you're not pro war if you
question Donald Trump's decision you're
not a hypocrite if you're concerned
about the timings and the motivations
the military should exist to prevent
genocide when possible and pulling out
of Syria increases the risk of genocide
against the Kurds and of more killing by
Assad of his own people period and it is
truly an amazing time to live in when
Noam Chomsky is the voice of reason
against a Republican presidents erratic
pulling troops out of the Middle East as
the person saying as Chomsky is saying
wait a second let's think this through
before we do it yeah
2018 almost 2019 it's an interesting
time to live in everything's flipped on
its head I tend to agree with the
decision to pull out of Syria but points
made by Noam Chomsky they do give me
pause I always want to listen to what he
has to say because I do view him as a
authority on these matters but like what
you said earlier it doesn't mean that
he's always right doesn't mean that we
have to take his word as gospel it's a
crazy time we live in isn't it now Pat
gee you separate so let's see why is it
you want the troops out but then how do
you consider the motivations of Trump
for doing it like can you say it's good
that the troops are out but we need to
investigate exactly why Trump did it and
why now in principle I think we should
have fewer interventions around the
world I'd really like to be scaled a
military-industrial complex that's for
sure especially because I think that the
missions that we set out to accomplish
in Syria have been completed but I can
understand the two things can be true at
once that it may be the right decision
to pull out of Syria and that Trump
could be doing it for malicious reasons
all right let's if you have questions
about this I am taking questions on the
david pakman show instagram page all day
today at david pakman show if you look
at my Instagram story you can type in a
question if you have questions about
Syria or anything else find me there I
will answer them and while you're on
Instagram make sure to follow me as well
at David Pakman one of today's sponsors
is Skillshare which is an incredible
online learning community offering over
10,000 high-quality online courses on a
huge variety of topics first 500 who
click the link under this video will get
two entire months of totally free access
to every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than 10 bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up